[music]
>> I've done a Venn diagram
impact and effectiveness of a public
talk. 7% matter and content of the talk.
93% is presentation of the talk.
And many a time
people may agree
people may disagree.
Some may say 8%.
Some may say 6%. Some may say 9.
If it differs by one or two percent here
or there, don't argue.
But surely
the matter does not carry
more than 10% weightage.
Every research
has a different opinion.
And just to give an example, according
to
you,
which
is the best matter available on the face
of the earth today?
Yes, brother. Uh the glorious Quran.
Correct. The best available matter on
the face of the earth is the
glorious Quran. No Muslim
will differ with that. The non-Muslim
may differ. Every Muslim agrees that
Quran is the best book available on the
face of the earth. Why? Because it is
the word of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
It's Kalamullah.
Now,
if suppose I pick up the best matter on
the face of the earth.
This is the Quran.
And
I read it.
I'm reading it.
A'uzubillahiminashaitanirajim.
Bismillahirahmanirahim.
Say, "Call upon other gods whom you
fancy to be as Allah. You know about
them on the bit of an atom. They have no
other than no such share they have.
There is no any help of Allah."
Did you get the message? Can anyone
repeat what I said?
No one. Why? It is Kalamullah. It is the
translation. What I read is not
Kalamullah. It is the translation
of the Quran.
Why?
Because I was breaking almost all the
rules
of public speaking.
Can anyone give the gist of what I
spoke?
No one.
You don't understand English?
Brother Ibrahim, what I spoke?
I I couldn't understand that.
I couldn't listen. Clear.
Can you understand English?
Now you're understanding.
When I read the translation of the
Quran, you didn't understand. Why?
Clarity.
I was breaking most of the rules
of public speaking.
Now, if I have to read it,
I would just read this last money.
And I'm picking up any chapter.
Say,
"Call upon other gods whom you fancy
besides Allah. They have no power
nor the weight of an atom
in the heavens or on the earth.
No sort of share have they therein
nor in any of them
a helper of Allah."
Nobody there right?
Did you get the message?
Yes or no?
Yes.
Now, the first time when I read the
words of the Quran,
it was the breaking most of the rules of
public speaking. And I did not
pick up a passage.
I just opened the Quran anywhere
and read the translation.
Though I don't have the habit of reading
from the book actually.
So, the difference is
in the technique. But natural.
When I repeat in my lecture,
that time the public speaking skills are
better.
Why? We will come to know
when we go ahead.
Point number two of the introduction,
the Islamic perspective of a public
talk.
What I spoke earlier is just the impact
and effectiveness
of a public talk. Here Islamic
perspective of public talk.
And it's very important.
It says, matter and content plus
presentation multiplied by compatibility
of the matter and presentation with
Quran and authentic Hadith.
Besides the matter
and the presentation skills,
this is multiplied with the
compatibility with Quran
and authentic Hadith.
That is equal to effectiveness
of an Islamic public talk.
This is the second point. And this is
very important. Why?
For example,
I will come and give a speech
on
the benefits of alcohol.
And with all my skills,
with all my presentation skills, with my
technique, with my gestures,
with my statistics,
I convince most of my audience that
every day you should at least have one
peg of alcohol.
Matter is there.
Presentation skills,
maybe more than 90.
But compatibility with the Quran and
Sunnah is
is
zero. So, Islamic effectiveness,
zero.
Because of this, the matter carries
weight
in
Islamic effectiveness
of a public talk. Even your presentation
skills should follow Quran and Sunnah.
We'll come to it.
Not only matter, matter is important.
Even your presentation skills should not
break
the rules
and the teachings of Quran and sahih
Hadith. People normally think that the
matter should be Islamic halal.
Even the presentation skills should not
break the rules of Quran and Sunnah.
And by the time we touch on the various
aspects of presentation skills, you'll
also realize how can the presentation
skills many a time
break the Quran and Sunnah, or many a
time how can it confirm
or strengthen
the Quran and Sunnah.
So, it's not only with matter,
even the presentation skills should
confirm and adhere to the Quran and
Sunnah.
So, if you attend a normal public
speaking course,
or any course
in which you get knowledge,
whether it be medicine, whether it be
engineering, anything,
if that expert
Quran says
in Surah An-Nahl, chapter 16, verse 43,
and Surah Al-Anbiya, chapter number 21,
verse number seven, "Fas'alu ahla zikri
in kuntum la ta'lamun."
If you don't know, ask the person who's
an expert.
While you're learning engineering or
management,
many a time
there are things which they tell you
against Quran and Sunnah. At that time,
anything which contradicts with Allah
and his Rasul,
you have to follow Allah and his Rasul.
Let him be the biggest expert in the
world. Let it be the best training in
the world. Let it
be the person who's got the biggest
award in the world.
That's what I told you yesterday,
that intentionally, inshallah, I'll not
do anything which
contradicts the Quran and Sunnah.
Unintentionally, if I happen to do, in
my ignorance, anything which goes
against Quran and Sunnah, you reject
Zakir Naik, he's zero in Islam.
You follow Quran and Sunnah.
So, even in this training program, if
anything I say
contradicts the Quran and Sunnah, reject
it. But,
if you find something is not
matching the Quran and Sunnah, please
ask.
As I told you yesterday, many a times
you may think it is against Quran and
Sunnah, and 99.9% you may be wrong.
Because our intention is not to break
Quran and Sunnah, my intention is not to
break any single dot
or letter of the Quran and Sunnah.
So, you may not be aware and you may
think because of your little knowledge
that 0.1% is yet there that we are human
beings, we can make mistakes.
So, if you find anything is
wrong,
ask
that
how come this
is matching in the Quran? Is that clear?
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah
Allah